bien mesdames messieurs bonjour à toutes
et à tous ce conseil des ministres a
bien entendu une nouvelle fois été
largement consacré à l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire les chiffres sont
éloquents et témoignent tous d'une même
réalité l'épidémie est aujourd'hui plus
forte que jamais dans notre pays jamais
le virus n'a circulé autant jamais le
virus n'a été aussi présent et ce sur
l'ensemble du territoire sur l'ensemble
du territoire en compte désormais près
de 300 mille cas détectés par jour en
moyenne soit près de 2 millions de cas
positifs en une semaine et le taux
d'incidence approche des 2800 cas pour
100000 habitants un niveau jamais connu
si le virus et son variant ultra
contagieux omicron est désormais présent
partout sur le territoire certains
départements restent nettement plus
touchés que les autres ainsi le taux
d'incidence dépasse les 1000 dans tous
les territoires il dépasse les 4000 dans
six départements paris la seine saint
denis le val de marne le val d'oise
l'essonne et la haute savoie surtout
deux vagues co existent encore dans
notre pays 6 ohms et kroon représente
aujourd'hui 9 contamination sur 10 le
variant delta fait de la résistance et
le nombre de cas delta reste élevé même
s'il commence à diminuer et il y à des
disparités territoriales importante sur
ce point cette vague delta nous la
ressentons encore fortement notamment
dans les services de réanimation la
tension y est toujours de plus en plus
forte avec près de 4000 patients qu'aux
vide en soins critiques soit 75% de nos
capacités totales en une semaine le
nombre de patients hospitalisés a
augmenté de 18 % et le nombre de
patients en soins critiques de 8% cela
se confirme grâce au vaccin grâce
notamment au près de 30 millions de
français qui ont déjà reçu une dose de
rappel nous avons fait dérailler la
mécanique virale infernale entre
contamination et hospitalisations et
dans cet océan de cas il existe
aujourd'hui néanmoins quelques
éclaircies d'abord omicron confirme sa
moindre sévérité et il semble que les
hospitalisations dues à ce variant sont
en général moins grave est moins longue
que les autres là tension à l'hôpital
continue de croître mais heureusement
sans commune mesure par rapport au
nombre de cas détectés ensuite un regard
sur le royaume uni qui a souvent était
en avance de 10 à 15 jours sur nous en
matière de dynamique épidémique laisse
espérer comme le disent certains
scientifiques comme mikron pourrait
bientôt atteindre son pic au royaume uni
le nombre de cas quotidiens a commencé à
baisser c'est un signal encourageant
mais il nous faut bien sûr éviter de
nous garder de crier au pic trop tôt
surtout nous ne savons pas encore si ce
pic sera suivie d'une décrue ou d'un
plateau mais une nouvelle fois nous
avons de réels motifs d'espérance le
vaccin protège contre les formes graves
et limite réduit les transmissions les
dose de rappel sont particulièrement
efficaces contre omicron en matière de
farms grave et nous avons repris la
vaccination à un rythme rapide les
gestes barrières sont toujours
protecteur et de petites décisions
peuvent emporter de grands bénéfices
comme l'a souligné l'institut pasteur
une diminution de 20 % de nos contacts
peut diviser par deux le nombre
d'hospitalisations des semaines à venir
demain des coupes dépend encore donc de
nous mais malgré les chiffres
vertigineux de l'épidémie nous ne
dévions pas de notre cap ce cap il est
clair et plus indispensable que jamais
nous voulons vivre le plus normalement
possible malgré le virus et avec
pragmatisme constance et détermination
nous tenons ce cap nous le tenons
notamment à l'école l'école en france
c'est un choix c'est une affirmation
c'est une fierté les études le montrent
les écoles en france sont fermés deux
fois moins qu'en allemagne trois fois
moins qu'en italie quatre fois moins
qu'aux états unis depuis le début de
cette crise nous pouvons être fiers les
médecins les pédiatres les psychiatres
et les professeurs nous alerte sans
cesse depuis deux ans sur le fait que
lorsque l'on ferme des classes on
sacrifie la santé on sacrifie
l'éducation on sacrifie l'avenir de nos
enfants c'est une décision que nous
devons éviter à tout prix car comme le
souligne la société française de
pédiatrie elle aurait des conséquences
dramatiques
chaque journée sans école c'est en effet
un risque accru de décrochage c'est
moins de temps d'apprentissage des
fondamentaux et ce sont des inégalités
qui se creusent entre les enfants
chaque journée sans école ce sont des
enfants isolés parfois désemparés et une
souffrance psychique accentuée pour les
plus fragiles d'entre eux chaque journée
sans école ce sont des milliers
d'enfants privés de cantine d'activités
sportives et d'interaction sociale
autant d'éléments qui sont nous le
savons indispensables à leur
développement
et derrière les classes fermées ce
serait toute la société qui baisserait
le rideau parce qu'une classe fermée ce
sont des dizaines de parents empêché de
travailler et cela aurait soyez-en
certains des conséquences délétères sur
notre système de transport sur nos
services publics sur la vie quotidienne
de nos concitoyens
alors chacun aujourd'hui doit mesurer
les conséquences de ces propositions
avec 300 mines contamination par jour
fermer une classe au premier cas positif
cela signifierait en quelques jours
fermez la quasi totalité des
établissements scolaires cela aurait
certes le mérite de la simplicité sans
doute mais ce serait dangereux pour les
enfants pénalisant pour les parents et
cela excéderait largement les
recommandations sanitaires
l'éducation ne sera jamais pour nous une
variable d'ajustement la fermeture des
écoles ne sera jamais une solution de
facilité elle doit toujours rester un
ultime recours c'est le sens des
protocoles que nous mettons en place
aujourd'hui nous pouvons éviter les
fermetures de classes suivant les
recommandations des autorités
scientifiques notamment celle du haut
conseil à la santé publique nous avons
mis en place un protocole à la fois
pragmatique et protecteur il repose sur
une limitation dé brassage entre les
élèves sur le port du masque et surtout
il s'appuie sur une stratégie de
dépistage massif et ciblées oui nous
leur connaissons évidemment tout n'a pas
été parfait au cours de ces derniers
jours sur le protocole nous savons
combien la situation est difficile
combien allait éprouvante pour les
parents comme pour les personnels de
l'éducation nationale et en raison de
l'arrivée tardive des préconisations
sanitaire du haut conseil de ce que nous
avons appris au fur et à mesure de ce
que nous avons constaté sur le terrain
nous avons dit oui nous adapter en
permanence pour ne pas laisser gagner le
virus certaines informations sont
arrivés tardivement c'est vrai et nous
mesurons qu'elle peut être et quelle est
la fatigue et l'inquiétude des parents
comme des personnels de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer le mini
de l'éducation nationale l'a encore
rappelé nous avons écouté nous avons
ajusté oui mais toujours un équilibre et
trouver un équilibre qui permet d'éviter
des tests superflu d attente trop longue
et surtout des classes fermées avec
trois cent mille cas par jour seulement
2% de classes sont fermées aujourd'hui
avec le précédent protocole je le redis
la fermeture du le nombre de classes
fermées aurait été massif nous
préservons l'école et la santé de chacun
avec pragmatisme c'est pourquoi
désormais vous le savez on demande de
pratiquer trois auto test et non plus un
test anti génie coupé cr suivi de deux
auto test c'est pourquoi les parents
n'auront plus qu'une attestation et non
plus trois à remplir c'est pourquoi les
parents enfin pourront retrouver leurs
enfants en fin de journée de classe si
les cas contacts et non plus
immédiatement comme c'était le cas
précédemment
ce protocole a juste et c'est simple
c'est moins d'attentes plus de souplesse
est toujours la sécurité sanitaire nous
assumons et nous revendiquons même ce
choix de l'école ouverte nous préférons
la complexité du travail à la facilité
de la fermeture nous préférons tester
plutôt que fermer les écoles sont à
l'image de notre volonté gardez le pays
ouvert et aujourd'hui grâce à notre
stratégie nous avons de bonnes raisons
d'être confiants nous tenons le cap d'un
pays ouvert grâce à la vaccination nous
assumons d'aller le plus loin possible
dans notre effort vaccinale en
instaurant notamment le pass vaccinale
qui devrait entrer en vigueur dès la
semaine prochaine se passe il produit
déjà des effets par sa simple évocation
et la forte reprise des primo injection
que nous avons connu la semaine dernière
en témoigne encore une fois il faut bien
voir que sans notre couverture vaccinale
sans l'efficacité exceptionnelle des
vaccins et du rappel nous ne parlerions
pas aujourd'hui des difficultés à mettre
en place des protocoles et des tests
mais bien des fermetures et des
confinement nous tenons le cap d'un pays
ouvert grâce à notre hôpital l'hôpital
où nous avons massivement réinvesti dès
la fin de la première vague tiens je
veux le dire admirablement le choc face
à la vague actuelle je veux saluer le
courage la mobilisation l'engagement des
soignants qui réalise encore des
exploits quotidien pour prendre en
charge l'ensemble des malades et nous
avons pris dans le cadre du ségur et
encore récemment des mesures sans
précédent pour reconnaître leurs
engagements nous tenons le cap d'un pays
ouvert surtout grâce à l'immense
responsabilité des français dans cette
crise partout dans notre pays on n'a
jamais autant effectuer de tests près de
12 millions de tests par semaine sont
réalisés ces tests sont indispensables
pour prévenir et freiner les
contaminations liées à ce variant encore
une fois extrêmement contagieux et parce
que ces tests sont indispensables pour
protéger l'ensemble des français nous
augmentons chaque semaine nos capacités
en la matière partout où cela sera
nécessaire nous démultiplieront les
lieux de dépistage ainsi que les moyens
logistiques pour nos pharmacies et dès
cette semaine 11 millions d'autos tests
supplémentaires seront livrés aux
officines je rappelle qu'il y en avait
encore 6 million en stocks en fin de
semaine dernière les français sont
exemplaires et pourtant nous savons
l'immense lassitude que chacun ressent
face à cette crise et s'il ya
aujourd'hui un argument une
justification à notre politique actuelle
c'est bien la volonté de limiter au
maximum les effets de cette crise sur le
quotidien des français qui ont déjà tant
donné et qui donne encore temps pour
vivre avec le virus nous ne dévierons
jamais de ce cap protéger et permettre
la liberté et la tranquillité de tous
c'est notre cap face à la crise c'est
plus largement notre cap pour la
sécurité des français pour nous la
sécurité ne se paye pas de mots pour
nous la sécurité c'est un bilan fort
plutôt que des slogans tapageurs pour
nous la sécurité ce sont des décisions
fermes plutôt que des images du passé
lundi le président de la république
s'est donc rendu à nice pour marquer le
lancement de la construction d'un nouvel
hôtel de toutes les polices à cette
occasion il a réaffirmé sa volonté
intacte d'assurer la sécurité des
français jusqu'à la dernière seconde de
son mandat il a présenté les grandes
orientations de la loi de programmation
du ministère de l'intérieur issu d'un
travail de plusieurs mois menée lors du
beauvau de la sécurité et qui sera
présentée vous le savez au début du mois
de mars nous avons évoqué ce matin bien
sûr notre action en matière de sécurité
qui nous mobilise depuis le premier jour
du quinquennat et le ministre de
l'intérieur a présenté un bilan de notre
action en compagnie de l'amie délégué
marlène schiappa durant ce quinquennat
la sécurité a retrouvé des moyens une
hausse historique du budget du ministère
de l'intérieur de 3,5 milliards d'euros
en cinq ans dix mille recrutements
supplémentaires de policiers et de
gendarmes là où d'autres avaient fait de
la sécurité
des coups de hachoir dans les effectifs
et surtout une volonté cela une volonté
que cela ne s'arrête pas là comme le
président de la république l'a annoncé
lundi la loi de programmation qui sera
présentée en mars prévoira une
augmentation supplémentaire de 15
milliards d'euros du budget du ministère
pour les cinq années à venir durant ce
quinquennat les policiers ont retrouvé
le terrain avec nos moyens
supplémentaires nous avons eu pour
priorité absolue de remettre du bleu
dans les rues et en quatre ans la
présence sur la voie publique a augmenté
de 10% pour aller plus loin le président
de la république a annoncé hier des
mesures en matière du temps de travail
et d'effectifs les mesures qui
permettront un doublement de la présence
sur la voie publique d'ici à 2030 ces
résultats sont visibles puisque
l'insécurité dans les transports a
reculé de 6% et les atteintes aux biens
de 15% durant ce quinquennat la
prévention des violences sexuelles et
sexistes est devenu une priorité absolue
nous avons mené un travail inédit de
formation de 90 mille policiers et
gendarmes mis en place mille bracelet
anti rapprochement a créé plusieurs
milliers de places d'hébergement pour
les victimes pour aller encore plus loin
là encore dans ce combat encore loin
d'être gagné le président a annoncé un
triplement de la bande pour outrage
sexistes cette amende sera portée à 300
euros et le nombre d'enquêteurs
spécialisés sera doublé durant ce
quinquennat la réponse judiciaire à
retrouver sa juste place au coeur de
l'action de l'état depuis le premier
jour nous avons une ferme volonté
d'avancer sur deux jambes
l'ambition sécuritaire et la réponse
pénale en cinq ans le budget du
ministère de la justice a augmenté de
33% et les effectifs du ministère de la
justice se sont renforcés de plus de
7000 personnes nous avons également
renforcé notre arsenal pénal en
alourdissant les peines contre les
agresseurs des forces de l'ordre ou
enfin en réformant le code de justice
des mineurs réforme qui avait été tant
annoncé puis des années que nous avons
menée à son terme pour mettre fin à
cette aberration avec des mineurs qui se
retrouvaient jugé sanctionné parfois 18
mois après la commission des faits
désormais ce sera six mois maximum et
nous mettons les moyens pour parvenir à
cet objectif pour accélérer encore
davantage ses procédures et accroître
l'efficacité de la justice le président
a annoncé hier une généralisation des
amendes forfaitaires pour les délits
punis de moins d'un an de prison durant
ce quinquennat les trafiquants de drogue
ont vu leur tranquillité mise à mal en
2021 les saisies de cocaïne par exemple
doublé et celle de cannabis ont augmenté
de 12% rien que sur l'année 2020 nous
avons assisté à une hausse de 24% des
trafics démantelés dans notre pays et au
delà de ces bons résultats nous avons
choisi de changer de paradigme
désormais chacun fait face à ses
responsabilités y compris les
consommateurs de stupéfiants qui ont
reçu 100 6000 amendes forfaitaires en
2021 durant ce quinquennat enfin la
république a repris pied partout sur le
territoire nous avons emmené a en effet
mené une lutte sans merci contre toutes
les atteintes aux principes républicains
la loi confortant les principes
républicains renforce ainsi la laïcité
dans les services publics comme dans les
associations tout en garantissant une
éducation républicaine à l'ensemble des
enfants dès le plus jeune âge
d'ores et déjà l'action de l'état dans
les territoires a permis de fermer plus
de 700 structure séparatistes et de
saisir ou de redresser 46 millions
d'euros d'avoirs mesdames messieurs ce
conseil des ministres a également été
l'occasion d'examiner plusieurs textes
j'y reviens rapidement le ministre d
outre-mer a présenté un projet de loi
ratifiant une ordonnance étend dans des
dispositions statutaires de la fonction
publique territoriale à plusieurs
communes de polynésie française
concrètement il s'agit de donner un
statut clair adapté et sécurisé aux
fonctionnaires communaux ensuite le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation a présenté un projet de
loi ratifiant une ordonnance en matière
de surveillance de prévention et de
lutte contre les maladies animales
transmissibles
il s'agit d'améliorer notre sécurité
alimentaire et celle de nos éleveurs
notamment en offrant une gouvernance
sanitaire plus clair en améliorant la
traçabilité à nîmes et en permettant une
gestion coordonnée au niveau européen
enfin le ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement et de la participation
citoyenne a présenté une communication
relative au bilan de l'application des
lois vous le savez rien ne détruit plus
la confiance que des annonces qui ne
sont pas suivies d'effet que des textes
qui ne s'incarne pas dans la vie
quotidienne des français nous avons
voulu tout au long du quinquennat mettre
fin au fossé entre l' annonce faite au
niveau national et le quotidien entre
les textes et la réalité comme nous nous
y étions engagés les actes suivent les
mots et 92% des loi était appliquée au
31 décembre 2021 c'est au dessus de la
moyenne du quinquennat et des
quinquennat précédent ce n'est pas fini
non plus puisque toutes les
administrations restent mobilisés
jusqu'au bout pour assurer que nos
décisions se change en fait voilà
mesdames messieurs ce que je pouvais
vous dire de ce conseil des ministres et
je me tiens à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
monsieur le ministre bonjour allison
tassin pour tf1 et lci vous évoquez un
océan de contamination ce matin or
l'académie de médecine se dit en faveur
d'une obligation vaccinale elle vous
appelle même à oser à franchir le pas
est ce qu'il ya un travail du
gouvernement en ce sens que ce soit pour
l'ensemble de la population simplement
pour les catégories de population comme
cela est fait en italie par exemple
on a toujours été clair sur le fait que
notre objectif c'est d'avoir la
couverture vaccinale la plus large
possible je crois que c'est un objectif
qui est par ailleurs partagé dans le
monde entier à partir de là vous avez
des réflexions dans chaque pays sur le
meilleur moyen de parvenir à cet
objectif vous avez des pays qui ont fait
le choix de dire pour atteindre cet
objectif d'une couverture vaccinale très
large on va annoncer une obligation
vaccinale on va la mettre dans la loi et
puis on mettra une amende dès lors qu on
contrôlera des personnes qui ne sont pas
vaccinés est ce qu'on a constaté dans
ces pays une hausse massive importante
de la vaccination à la suite de ces
annonces pas à ma connaissance tout cas
pas dans les premières données dont nous
disposons nous on va faire votre choix
qui est de dire pour parvenir à ce même
objectif on passe par le pass sanitaires
et demain par le pass vaccinale est ce
qu'on a constaté une hausse
massive importante du nombre de
personnes qui vont se faire vacciner à
la suite de ces dispositifs la réponse
est oui je rappelle 12 millions de
personnes qui se sont fait vacciner
après l'annnonce du pass sanitaires et
depuis l'annnonce du pass vaccinale
alors même qu'il n'est pas encore entré
en vigueur nous avons vu une nouvelle
hausse des primes aux injections la
semaine dernière plus de 200 mille
adultes qui ont réalisé une primo
injection c'est un record depuis je
crois la fin de l'été dernier donc nous
avons cette stratégique et c'est d'une
incitation maximale qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle nous permet
d'avoir une couverture vaccinale une des
plus importantes qui nous placent dans
le peloton de tête des pays en europe en
matière de couverture vaccinale et nous
restons sur ce cap finir sur l'académie
elle recommande aussi peut-être détendre
se passe notamment au transport ou au
lieu de travail est ce que là aussi on
travaille en ce sens il ya un débat
parlementaire puisque vous savez que un
texte est examiné au parlement qu'il a
été examiné à l'assemblée nationale
qu'il est en ce moment examiné ou sénat
et donc c'est le travail des
parlementaires que de regarder dans
quelle mesure l'extension du passé
possible ou non vous savez qu'il ya eu
des débats et des réflexions à un moment
donné sur la question de l'entreprise et
du travail que suite aux discussions qui
ont eu lieu entre le gouvernement les
partenaires sociaux suite au travail des
parlementaires aussi puisqu'un certain
nombre se sont penchés sur cette
question il a été considéré que ce
serait assez compliquée à mettre en
oeuvre et que ça ne servirait pas
particulièrement l'objectif de
couverture vaccinale plus que le cadre
du pass actuelle mais évidemment les
discussions parlementaires se poursuivre
tant que le texte est au parlement
bonjour anne jan hus baume de bloomberg
news est une question sur les
restrictions aux frontières avec le
royaume uni un député un des pieds qui
représentent les français de l'étranger
évoque une relaxation de ces
restrictions dans les jours à venir est
ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer je
vous avais annoncé je crois au dernier
compte rendu du conseil des ministres
qu'il faisait suite par ailleurs un
conseil de défense un premier
assouplissement dans les mesures de
restriction à la frontière avec le
royaume uni avec l'élargissement des
motifs professionnels pour se rendre en
france j'avais indiqué qu'il y aurait
ensuite si nous continuons à constater
la même situation c'est à dire
globalement invariants omicron qui est
largement devenu majoritaire
en france évidemment que nous
continuerions à
alléger les restrictions qui existe et
donc je vous confirme qu'à un
assouplissement supplémentaire des
restrictions avec le royaume-uni dallas
traction frontière avec le royaume uni
va être annoncé dans les tout prochains
jours je peux pas encore moi vous faire
les annonces puisque les travaux se
poursuivre mais effectivement comme
l'indiqué le député holroyd c'est bien
une perspective pour les prochains jours
les prochains jours ça veut dire quoi
est ce que ça pourrait être la semaine
prochaine mercredi prochain la porte au
plus vite si je vous dis les prochains
jours c'est pas la semaine prochaine
évidemment il ya des travaux qui se
poursuivent j'espère que d'ici la fin de
la semaine les annonces auront pu être
fait
bonjour olivier galibert pour rtl demain
la grève dans l'éducation nationale
s'annonce assez conséquente assez
massive hier le président a dit qu'il
comprenait la lassitude du monde
enseignant il ya eu cet ajustement dans
l'est dans les protocoles cet allégement
mais souvent aussi on leur en temps on
entend bomba tenez bon il faut encore
tenir un petit peu est-ce que cet
allègement et ses mots d'encouragement
sont suffisants pour répondre à cette
lassitude et quelle quelle est la bonne
réponse à apporter face à sète ce cri de
colère qui s'exprimera demain la réponse
est évidemment un travail main dans la
main c'est ça la réponse moi je veux
redire évidemment que nous comprenons
que nous entendons la fatigue la
lassitude des enseignants des personnels
éducatifs des familles aussi il faut le
dire nous avons fait ce choix et nous
l'assumons de laisser les écoles
ouvertes et encore une fois nous n'avons
pas le regretter quand on regarde les
pays qui les ont fermé deux fois plus
que nous trois fois plus que nous quatre
fois plus que nous peut pas dire qu'ils
aient une situation sanitaire
particulièrement meilleure que la nôtre
en revanche ils ont probablement des
retards accumulés pour les élèves pour
les enfants qui sont très importants là
où nous avons pu les limites et les
réduire au maximum donc nous assumons ce
choix qui n'est pas un choix de la
facilité c'est certain le plus simple
entre guillemets ça serait de dire on
ferme les écoles vous auriez pas
effectivement de protocole sanitaire à
construire ensuite à adapter au regard
de la situation constatée mais jamais
nous ne ferons le choix de la facilité
et oui c'est difficile évidemment
laisser les écoles ouvertes avec un
protocole sanitaire à la fois sécurisant
et simple dans un contexte vous avez une
très forte circulation
du virus donc on entend parfaitement la
lassitude et la fatigue des enseignants
et moi je veux à nouveau dire que nous
rendons hommage évidemment alors
mobilisation à leurs engagements parce
que depuis le début de cette crise ils
ont été au rendez vous ils l'ont été
notamment pendant le tout premier
confinement vous souvenez qu'à ce moment
là comme partout dans le monde les
écoles avaient été fermées ils ont été
remarquables d'inventivité pour
poursuivre l'enseignement à distance et
puis ensuite on a fait le choix de
maintenir les écoles ouvertes et ils ont
été au rendez vous et je veux le saluer
il ya plusieurs mots d'ordre pour cette
grève vous avez certains syndicats il me
semble qu'ils appellent à une certaine
mesure une certaine manière fermer les
écoles puisque il appelle à revenir à la
règle inca égale une fermeture de classe
qui est une règle qui existait à un
moment nous n'avions pas le variant
omicron qui est beaucoup plus contagieux
qui semble par ailleurs être moins
sévère je le redis adopter cette règle
ce serait fermé nos écoles et nous ne
faisons pas ce choix vous avez d'autres
mots d'ordre qui sont portées par des
syndicats précisément sur lesquels nous
travaillons avec eux moi je veux redire
que jean michel blanquer est en contact
permanent avec les syndicats
d'enseignants et que nous avons
travaillé avec eux sur les différents
sujets qui sont mis en avant dans leur
mobilisation je pense à la question des
capteurs de co2 on a mis en place et a
fait un long moment maintenant un fonds
de 20 millions d'euros pour permettre
aux collectivités locales qui n'auraient
pas les moyens de s'équiper en capteur
de co2 c'est elle qui sont responsables
des infrastructures pour les écoles donc
c'est de leur compétence mais évidemment
nous ne souhaitons pas que pour des
raisons financières une collectivité ne
puisse pas s'équiper en capteur de co2
on a mis en place un fonds de 20
millions d'euros et je constate
d'ailleurs qu'il n'est pas consommée
dans son intégralité ce qui montre que
probablement que des collectivités qui
ne les ont pas encore mis en place pour
l e sollicité je leur renouvelle l'appel
pour équiper leurs classes vous avez
ensuite des revendications en matière de
remplacement parce que c'est vrai que
quand un prof est malade qui doit
s'isoler évidemment le souhaitent et
qu'il puisse y avoir une continuité dans
sa classe et sur ce point je rappelle
que nous avons augmenté de 30%
vivier de remplaçants dont nous
disposons il est de 9% en temps normal
des effectifs de l'éducation nationale
pour pouvoir parer aux absences liées à
la maladie et d'isolement de professeurs
qui serait positif à la copie donc là
aussi nous avançons sur tous ces sujets
la question des masques aussi des
annonces qui ont été faites sur la
livraisons de masques chirurgicaux
nous avons avancé parce qu'il ya ce
dialogue et ce travail avec les
syndicats d'enseignants et évidemment
que ce dialogue ce travail va se
poursuivre la porte de jean michel
blanquer est toujours ouverte pour
discuter avec les enseignants et avancer
ensemble
bonjour monsieur le ministre mathieu
coatch bfm tv pour revenir sur ce que
vous venez de dire je crois que ce qui
est reproché finalement gouvernement
c'est pas tant le fait d'ouvrir les
écoles mais les parents et la plupart
des enseignants se plaignent des
annonces multiples compliqué annoncé au
dernier moment est-ce que sur ceux sur
le plan de la communication de la
transmission des informations
vous constatez qu'il ya eu des erreurs
peut-être ses dernières semaines ces dix
derniers jours et est ce que bien vous
allez faire un effort pour mieux
annoncer ces règles aux enseignants pas
le dimanche soir pour le lundi matin par
exemple je crois que j'ai dit dès mon
intervention liminaire mais dira jean
michel branquart l'avait dit le premier
ministre l'avait dit le président de la
république a eu l'occasion de le dire
dans une interview et un face aux
lecteurs au parisien la semaine dernière
évidemment que tout n'a pas été parfait
et évidemment
dira jamais que tout est parfait dans la
gestion de la crise par principe il peut
y avoir des loupés quand vous par
principe il peut y avoir
des annonces qui sont fait un peu au
dernier moment et c'est vrai que quand
vous recevez les recommandations du haut
conseil de la santé publique trois jours
avant la rentrée c'est vrai que ça vous
laisse peu de temps pour faire les
annonces comme ça a été le cas par jean
michel blanquer mais je le redis une
nouvelle fois nous préférons assumer ses
difficultés et oui des critiques
aujourd'hui sur un protocole et des
règles qui doivent s'adapter plutôt que
ceux d'hier le plus simple pour ne pas
être critiqué
ça serait probablement de fermer les
écoles parce qu'on ne dirait pas vous
vous adaptez vous changer la règle etc
mais là probablement que les critiques à
viendrait dans cinq dans dix ans ce
serait plus facile pour nous parce que
peut-être que ce serait d'autre alors
concernés mais elle viendrait parce
qu'on aurait constaté des années plus
tard des retards massif chez nos élèves
et ça nous ne le voulons pas ne voulons
pas nous retrouver dans une situation où
nos élèves se retrouvent a accumulé des
retards parce qu'ils n'ont pas accès à
l'éducation du fait de l'épidémie
afp alors la majorité de droite au sénat
propose que le pass vaccinale
disparaissent dès que le le nombre
d'hospitalisations passe sous les 10000
au niveau national est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à examiner une telle mesure où
jugez vous que qu'elle est inapplicable
il ya une discussion parlementaire qui
en cours et donc je veux pas m'immiscer
dans le dialogue entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat mais olivier viron
s'exprimer sur ce sujet ce matin il a
indiqué que ça ne lui semblait pas être
une piste qu'il fallait retenir est que
le pass vaccinale évidemment c'est une
mesure temporaire
évidemment que dès lors qu'on en aura
plus besoin pour réduire essayer de
réduire la circulation du virus et puis
surtout inciter fortement à la
vaccination évidemment qu'on s'en
débarrassera encore une fois c'est pas
dans notre adn c'est pas dans notre
logiciel on n'est pas fétichiste du pass
du tout dès qu'on pourra s'en
débarrasser on s'en débarrassera mais
une forme de règles automatiques liée à
un nombre de personnes hospitalisées
nous ne sommes pas être la bonne
solution sous prétexte qu'il y aurait
neuf mille neuf cents personnes et pas
dix mille et une personne hospitalisée
tout d'un coup il y aura plus besoin de
passes vaccinale dans notre pays donc
voilà je pense qu'il ya un enjeu de
clarté chez une partie des oppositions
sur ce qu'elle pense du pass vaccinale
je leur soutien on passe vaccinale on
l'a vu la semaine dernière à l'assemblée
nationale puisque les responsables du
parti à l'air avaient dit qu'ils
soutenaient le pass dax inhalent mais
que leurs députés ont voté contre dans
l'hémicycle donc il ne faudrait pas
finalement s'abriter derrière des
propositions dont chacun sait lequel
sont difficiles à mettre en oeuvre pour
ne pas être clair sur la position des
uns et des autres sur le pass vaccinale
j'ai juste une question edf annoncé ce
matin de nouveaux retards et surcoûts
pour le pr2 pleurs flamanville est ce
que vous regrettez cette annonce et est
ce qu'elle peut remettre en cause le
lancement de nouveaux projets de
construction de réacteurs que le
président devrait
détailler précisées dans les prochains
semaines alors edf a effectivement
informé le gouvernement d'un nouveau
calendrier pour la finalisation des
travaux de le p r de flamanville 3 pour
expliquer ce nouveau calendrier edf
invoque notamment deux dernières
campagnes d'essais avant le démarrage et
la nécessité de prendre en compte le
retour d'expérience de l' aléa technique
qui a été rencontré vous le savez sur un
réacteur en chine et d'ultime procédure
d'autorisation liés à la sûreté tout
cela dans un contexte industriel qui est
rendue vous le savez plus difficile par
la pandémie c'est ce sont des opérations
qui sont nécessaires pour assurer le bon
fonctionnement de la centrale dans des
conditions de sûreté conformes à la
réglementation et nous serons vigilants
à ce que des f tire les leçons des
différents retards qu'a connu ce
chantier afin d'améliorer son processus
industriel cela pour nous l'enjeu
general electric et edf ont trouvé un
accord pour la reprise des turbines
arabe elle est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour la souveraineté de la
france alors à ma connaissance les
échanges de négociations sont toujours
en cours entre les entreprises il n'y a
pas eu d'annoncé officielle et ce n'est
pas à moi de m'exprimer avant les
entreprises donc je suis prudent sur ce
sujet là je ne ferai pas de commentaire
sur cette information
bonjour monsieur le porte parole de
finnair ses news valérie pécresse
reproche à emmanuel macron d'être un
président candidat elle fait référence à
son déplacement à nice elle a saisi les
la commission des comptes de campagne
comment est ce que vous pouvez clarifier
en tout cas comment emmanuel macron peu
clarifié la situation est ce que les
règles peuvent changer autrement moi je
suis toujours assez surpris de
la fébrilité qui semble gagner à nîmes
et des responsables politiques dès lors
que le président de la république
s'exprime
j'ai pas l'habitude de commenter à ce
titre vous le savez les manoeuvres
politiciennes de campagne de
l'opposition je suis là dans mon rôle
institutionnel de porte parole du
gouvernement qui s'exprime à la sortie
du conseil des ministres ici à l'elysée
dans le cadre de très institutionnelle
de cette fonction mais moi je veux dire
que pour nous la sécurité ça n'est pas
uniquement un sujet de campagne c'est un
sujet d'action et donc je suis surpris
quand j'entends certains estimé que
quand on parle de sécurité ça veut dire
qu'on est en campagne voilà qu'il
faudrait être en campagne pour parler de
sécurité non nous la sécurité non
seulement on en parle mais on agit
depuis le début de ce quinquennat
certains font le choix des mots nous
faisons le choix des actes la
criminalité les trafics de drogue la
délinquance la lutte contre le
terrorisme tout ça ne se met pas en
pause trois mois avant une élection ça
serait même inquiétant de d'imaginer que
trois mois avant une élection des
délinquants des voyous des trafiquants
se dirait qu'il ya une élection dans
trois mois donc on va se mettre sur
pause banon vous savez très bien que ça
ne fonctionne pas comme ça et donc
évidemment le gouvernement jusqu'au bout
il doit continuer à agir et prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent pour protéger la
sécurité des français c'est ce
gouvernement ce président de la
république qui a permis le recrutement
de dix mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires depuis le début du
quinquennat qui a augmenté de 3
milliards et demi d'euros le budget du
ministère de l'intérieur qui a renouvelé
un tiers du parc automobile de nos
forces de l'ordre qui a rénové 700
commissariats et casernes pour nos
policiers et nos gendarmes qui a
renforcé notre politique pénale pour
lutter contre l'impunité et pour avoir
davantage de fermeté et de sévérité dans
notre pays et il est évidemment légitime
et normal qu'on continue à agir sur ce
terrain jusqu'au bout de ce quinquennat
c'est le mandat que nous donnez les
français malgré manifestement la
fébrilité de certains
à nouveau une question sur la grève qui
s'annonce pour demain vous dit que le
dialogue est permanent entre le ministre
de l'éducation nationale et les
syndicats mais est ce que la relation ne
s'est pas abîmer à force d'être tendue
et jean michel blanc car dit lui-même
qu'il en a marre de passer pour le père
fouettard est-ce qu'il ya pas tout
simplement un manque aussi de soutien de
la part des membres du gouvernement face
à cette crise maintenant je vous
confiant qu'on est tous très en soutien
de jean michel blanquer air qu on avance
comme un pack dans cette crise depuis le
début et c'est vrai que il ya eu des
difficultés depuis le début de cette
crise
et donc il ya une solidarité évidemment
entre les membres du gouvernement que
des décisions qui sont prises sont
prises de manière collégiale
je redis évidemment notre soutien au
ministre de l'éducation nationale dans
ce contexte je redis qu'il échange avec
les enseignants en permanence que c'est
un dialogue qui n'a jamais cessé que sa
porte est toujours ouverte pour
continuer à discuter avancer avec eux
son prochain directeur général c'est un
facteur assez déstabilisant pour
l'entreprise et quand on parle aux
acteurs impliqués il explique que la
décision finale viendra du gouvernement
et l'elysée donc voilà est-ce que vous
avez des informations sur le calendrier
ou le calendrier vous souhaiteriez
l'entrevoir adopté l'entreprise et un
avis sur les profils retenus jusqu'à
présent pour remplacer stéphane richard
non il ya un processus de sélection en
cours vous l'avez dit l'état est
actionnaire d'orange qu'il fait partie
mais ce n'est pas pour le coup à moins
porte parole du gouvernement que de
m'exprimer sur ce sujet par ailleurs un
processus de sélection en cours encore
une fois avec une méthode de sélection
donc gouvernement n'a pas fermé
ingérence non dans ce processus est sûre
sur ce point je crois que mon collègue
bruno le maire s'est exprimée encore ce
matin pour dire la manière dont nous
voyons les choses et je n'ai pas
davantage de l'information à donner sur
ce sujet à une question sur ce qui se
passe au royaume-uni comment est ce que
vous voyez les choses les accusations
contre boris johnson d'avoir organisé
une garden party en pleine épidémie est
ce que ça aurait pu se produire en
france est ce que ça vous choque j'ai
pas de commentaire à faire franchement
d'abord vous m'apprenez une partie de de
ces informations j'ai pas j'ai pas du
tout ça je n'ai pas de commentaires à
faire je pense que on l'a toujours dit
il ya cette crise un besoin de
responsabilité d'exemplarité au 6 qui
veut pas dire que parfois la hausse il
peut y avoir
des loupés bon je n'ai pas de
commentaires à faire vraiment
mon jean jacques sereys europe 1 il y
avait un conseil de défense et de
sécurité nationale sont atteints est ce
que vous observez des menaces de
déstabilisation ou d'ingérence étrangère
dans ce début de campagne présidentielle
il y à une vigilance évidemment très
forte pour nous protéger et protéger ce
moment démocratique et politique majeur
qu'est l'élection présidentielle
d'ingérence possible étrangère bien sûr
il ya des moyens qui sont mis en place
pour ça pour renforcer nos services de
cyberdéfense savez j'avais eu l'occasion
d'en faire des annonces à plusieurs
reprises ce pupitre depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois même plusieurs années je
veux rappeler aussi que landecy qui
permet de garantir la sécurité des
systèmes d'information dans notre pays
propose d'ailleurs une formation à
l'ensemble des candidats à la
présidentielle à leur équipe pour se
protéger évidemment de possibles
intrusions ingérence étrangère donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya une vigilance très
forte sur ce point
s'il ya pas d'autres questions je vous
remercie et je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine